alors nous allons maintenant revenir sur
l'histoire du tour de france dans les
yvelines mélanie poké journaliste chez
tv 78 vient nous présenter à cette
histoire du tour de france est une
longue histoire d'amour les yvelines et
tour de france et c'est une relation qui
débute dès la toute première édition en
1903 alors ne cherchez pas une ville du
département comme départ ou arrivée pour
cette édition le tour n'a que six étapes
alors le que et bien sûr entre
guillemets parce que l'étape la plus
courte parcours tout de même 2 168 km
mais ça qu'ils nous intéresse c'est la
dernière le 18 juillet les coureurs
s'élancent de nantes et le 19 juillet il
se départageront sur les routes
sinueuses de la vallée de chevreuse et
là c'est maurice garin piron porte et
l'étape et l'épreuve
alors si on s'intéresse juste aux villes
étapes le département a vu le peu le ton
emprunté ces routes à 46 reprises dont
24 rien que pour la ville de versailles
dès 1925 la grande boucle s'installe
dans les yvelines
la première étape est donné au vésinet
ville qui deviendra départ réel de la
course ensuite de 1927 à 1939
rambouillet l'accueillera à quatre
reprises saint germain en laye où ils et
mantes-la-jolie complètent le tableau
est à noter qu'en 1986 et une
agglomération qui voit arriver la
deuxième étape de l'épreuve une certaine
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et qui sera le
départ de la dernière étape du tour en
2023 et oui tout cela grâce à un
partenariat signé entre a et soul
organisation l'organisateur pardon de
l'épreuve et le département
il est signé en mars 2019 et quelques
mois plus tard la 21e étape de la grande
boucle s'est lancé de rambouillet le
maillot jaune était sur les épaules du
colombien et gagnent bernal alors le
dernier français à porter la tunique au
départ d'une étape yvelinoise c'est
laurent fignon en 1989 tunique qu'il
perdra malheureusement dans un final
tellement cruel sur les champs-elysées
l'année de ma naissance mais dany